في خان يونس تحديدا ينضم الينا مراسل
الجزيره مؤمن الشرافي من مستشفى ناصر في
خان يونس واخر المعلومات لديك
مؤمن نعم حسن قبل قليل الان وصل سيارات
اسعاف تقل جثامين خمسه من الشهداء تم
انتشالهم من شارع القدره في مدينه خان
يونس يقول المسعفون ان جثامين الشهداء
الخمسه محترقه تماما نتيجه قصف الاسرائيلي
الذي تعرضوا له في شارع القدره بمدينه
خانيونس لذلك بذلك يرتفع عدد الشهداء في
الذين وصلوا الى مجمع ناصر الطبي الى 60
شهيدا واكثر من 100 جريح بينهم العشرات في
حاله حرجه وخطيره ومن بينهم اطفال ونساء
القصف المدفعي ميدانيا والغارات الجويه
والاطلاق النار الكثيف من قبل الطائرات
المسيره في محيط مجمع ناصر الطبي لازال
مستمرا حتى هذه اللحظه حتى ان مقاتلات
الحربيه الاسرائيليه تحلق على ارتفاعات
منخفضه في مدينه خانيونس فيما تستمر
الاشتباكات في كافه محاور التوغل التي
وصلت اليها اليات ودبابات جيش الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي الان المقاتلات الحربيه
الاسرائيليه تح تحلق على ارتفاعات
منخفضه في اجواء مدينه خان يونس وايضا
اعمده الخان تتصاعد من المحور الشمالي
الشرقي في محيط شارع القسام ومنطقه
الكتيبه وايضا شارع خمسه وهذه المنطقه
تتواجد فيها اليات ودبابات جيش الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي قبل قليل طائره مسيره
اسرائيليه اطلقت نيرانها بكثافه في محيط
مجمع ناصر الطبي هذا المجمع الذي يعاني
ازمه كبيره نتيجه نقص الكوادر الطبيه
وايضا نقص الامكانيات لديهم والاعداد
الكبيره التي تصل حتى هذه اللحظه من
المصابين غرف العمليات امتلات عن بكره
ابيها وايضا المصابون بجروح خطيره ينتظرون
منذ ساعات الصباح دورهم للدخول في غرف
العمليات ما يفقد عدد منهم حياتهم
ويرتقي عدم توفر امكانيات لانقاذ حياتهم
القصف المدفعي يتجدد في المحور الجنوبي
والمنطقه الجنوبيه من مجمع ناصر وايضا
اليات الاحتلال المتوغلة
احتجزت قوات الاحتلال الكوادر الطبيه في
مستشفى الخير بعد سيطرتها على المنطقه
وبالتالي قطعت الطريق الواصل ما بين
مستشفى الخير الى مستشفى ناصر ومستشفى
الامل وبالتالي حتى طواقم الاسعاف التي
تحاول الوصول الى تلك المنطقه المنطقه
الغربيه التي يتواجد فيها العشرات من
الشهداء والمصابين ولا تستطيع الوصول
اليهم بالتالي لا تستطيع سيارات الاسعاف
الوصول الى المنطقه الغربيه لانتشال
جثامين الشهداء وانقاذ حياه الجرحى
والوصول بهم الى مستشفى ناصر الطبي هنا
نعم مؤمن
لنعود الى بعض الاحداث والتطورات التي
حصلت لا سما منها مزره مراكز الايواء
في المواسي ما هي اخر المعلومات الوارده
حتى اللحظه ا كان بالنسبه لاعداد الشهداء
والجرحى او كيفيه
التعامل مع
هذه الاصابات في
ظل هذا النقص الكبير في الطاقم الطبي
وايضا المعدات وعدم استيعاب مستشفى ناصر
في خانيونس لكل هذه
الاعداد جميع الاصابات التي وصلت الى
مستشفى ناصر هي من منطقه المواصي و منطقه
كان يدعي جيش الاحتلال انها امنه فتحت
مراكز ايواء كبيره في تلك المناطق سواء في
مدارس او داخل جامعه الاقصى او في حتى
الاراضي الزراعيه نصبت خيام ومخيمات
للنازحين قصفت هذه طيله ساعات الليل وحتى
ساعات الصباح من قبل دبابات جيش الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي وايضا من قبل الطائرات الحربيه
ما من تمكن من الوصول وعدد محدود من
سيارات الاسعاف في ساعات الصباح الباكر
تقريبا ثلاث سيارات اسعاف الى تلك المنطقه
وانتشل جثامين عدد من الشهداء حتى ان احد
المسعفين اخبرنا انهم اضطروا للابقاء على
جثامين الشهداء على الارض
وا واعطوا الاولويه لانقاذ حياه المصابين
والوصول بهم الى مستشفى ناصر يقول ان هناك
عدد كبير من الشهداء في عدد من المناطق في
منطقه المواصي سواء داخل مدارس او داخل
جامعه الاقصى او داخل اراضي زراعيه نصبوا
فيها مخيمات للنازحين تعرضت للقصف واخر
القصص هو الكفان الصغير لعائله غنام غرفه
صغيره دهستها الدبابات الاسرائيليه ما ادى
الى ارتقاء شهيد وشهيده وايضا وبقي من هذه
العائله سوا ثلاث اطفال وصلوا الى مستشفى
ناصر قبل قليل قصتهم مؤلمه
للغايه يعني حتى من من سلم من القصف
والصواريخ الاسرائيليه دهسته الدبابات
والاليات العسكريه الاسرائيليه في المنطقه
الغربيه من مدينه خانيونس مؤمن وانت
تحدثنا ونشاهد تحليق طيران اسرائيلي في
اجواء خان يونس ايضا نحن نسمع اصوات
انفجارات عنيفه يبدو انها بالقرب
منكم
على مدار الساعه حسن تتواصل هذه
الانفجارات الناجمه عن القصف المدفع
الكثيف سواء في محيط مجمع ناصر او المنطقه
الغربيه في عمومها وحي الامل الذي يتواجد
فيه مستشفى التابع لجمعيه الهلال الاحمر
ومركز الاسعاف الذي لا يستطيع منذ ساعات
الصباح الباكر الخروج من هذا المركز
والتحرك في المناطق التي يمكن الوصول
اليها لانتشال جتا مين الشهداء وانقاذ
حياه الجرحى والوصول بهم الى مستشفى ناصر
كافه المناطق في في مدينه خان يونس ليس
فقط محيط مجمع ناصر ولكن ايضا حي الامل
ومنطقه المشروع ومنطقه البلد المنطقه
الشماليه الغربيه حيث ابراج طيبه شارع
خمسه منطقه
المعسكر جميع المناطق في مدينه خان يونس
من شرقها الى غربها ومن شمالها الى جنوبها
تتعرض لقصف مدفعي كثيف وايضا غارات جويه
بين الفينه والاخرى بالاضافه الى تحليق
مكثف للطائرات المسيره الاسرائيليه من نوع
جواد كارتر والتي تفتح نيران اسلحتها الان
هذه نسخه صوره صغيره وبسيطه عبر سيارات
مدنيه ينقل المواطنون الجرحى والاصابات
الى مستشفى ناصر لعدم توفر سيارات الاسعاف
وعدم تمكن حتى سيارات الاسعاف التابعه
لجمعيه الهلال الاحمر من العمل في مختلف
المناطق الى مدينه خان يونس اي ال الوضع
صعب هنا حتى على صعيد تقديم الاسعافات
الاوليه
ل الجرحى المواطنون العاديون المدنيون اي
ليس لديهم خبره كافيه في كيفيه نقل الجريح
والوصول به بسلامه الى المستشفى حتى عندما
يصل الى قسم الاستقبال والطوارئ في مجمع
ناصر الطبي يفترشون الارض العشرات حتى هذه
اللحظه من الجرحى يفترشون الارض وينتظرون
دورهم لتقديم العلاج لهم او اخذ دور
لادخال لغرف العمليات ذكرت في نشرات سابقه
ان الاطباء حتى داخل غرف العمليات واداره
المستشفى تضطر مجبره
ل للاستخدام مبدا المفاضله في الجرحى
الحالات الميؤوس منها لا يدخلونها الى غرف
العمليات وبالتالي يفقد حياته ويعد في
عداد الشهداء وايضا الحالات المتوسطه التي
يمكن فيها امل في انقاذ حياتها يتم
ادخالها لغرف العمليات طوابير طويله من
الجرحى ينتظرون دورهم منذ ساعات الليل
وحتى هذه اللحظه لانقاذ حياتهم داخل غرف
العمليات اعمده الدخان التي تشاهدونها على
الشاشه هي في المحور الشمالي الشرقي من
مدينه خان يونس في محيط منطقه الكتيبه
وشارع خمسه وايضا شارع القسام الذي يشهد
منذ منذ ايام اشتباكات ضاريه بين المقاومه
وقوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي قوات الاحتلال
تحاول الوصول الى منطقه البلد في وسط
مدينه خنين اس من خلال هذا المحور على وجه
التحديد ولا نعرف طب بيع هذا الدخان
الصادر في من تلك المنطقه سواء كان قصف
منشات صناعيه او مباني سكنيه او استهداف
من قبل المقاومه الفلسطينيه لاليات
ودبابات جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
المتمركزه بشكل كثيف في المحور الشمال
الشرقي منطقه الكتيبه المحاطه والان نسمع
دوي انفجار قوي يبدو انه ناجم عن غاره
جويه اسرائيليه قريبه من مجمع ناصر الطبي